do you know that you can make it as an
entrepreneur is it you don't you just
gotta try you don't
patient and hustle yeah is that the key
that is the key now look i'm sure
there's a lot of kids or
grown-ups who actually feel the way i
did which was i knew
but i didn't really know it felt natural
it felt like i had it it seemed that
every time i put my foot in the water a
lemonade stand selling some baseball
cards trying to shovel snow
that i did well but until you do
something you don't fully know i think
the key right now is to make sure you're
not doing it because it's cool because
everybody else is doing it everybody
wants to start a business
everybody's got a side hustle
everybody's got an app idea that is a
modern day phenomenon that is a reaction
to the internet itself it's appropriate
and so
you don't necessarily know but if you
love it if it just gets you going
the idea of buying and selling something
or starting something or building a
community
you must scratch that itch because
regret is probably the thing that i fear
the most